there was a point yesterday where and it
wasn't a point it was most of the day if
you looked at the list of trending
topics on Twitter
it was NFL names all day long from Drew
Brees to Aaron Rodgers and others and it
was Drew Brees that that that by virtue
of something that was said yesterday
we're gonna play the sound for you
coming up that that has created an
avalanche of criticism of him from many
in the National Football League from
beyond the National Football League and
that that is one of the things that that
needs to be discussed presented and
dealt with and it was yesterday morning
on Instagram that Brees posted this
message there's a saying in every locker
room that I have been in don't just talk
about it be about it
acknowledge the problem and accept the
fact that we all have a responsibility
to make it better your actions speak so
loudly I can't hear what you're saying
nothing wrong with that great a product
of a moment and and and the moment that
that we've arrived at and I think this
really puts in context why there was
such a strong reaction the moment we've
arrived at for many people is an honest
assessment of their own views of what
Colin Kaepernick did four years ago and
almost an epiphany where anyone who was
against what Kaepernick was doing and
his method of communicating his message
that has fallen away and people are
saying boy if we'd only listened to
Colin Kaepernick how much of what has
happened would have been avoided how
many lives that were ended and that were
permanently affected by the loss of a
loved one or a close friend how many of
those lives would not have been lost if
we'd merely taking what he was saying
four years ago seriously and his message
was that he was trying to bring
awareness to the treatment of African
Americans and people of color by law
enforcement that was the message so
that's what I think set the stage for
that very visceral very raw and very
overwhelming reaction to the comments
from Drew Brees when he was appearing on
Yahoo Finance Daniel Roberts asked about
how drew will
spawned if given events that have
happened recently players decide to take
a knee during the national anthem in the
2020 season here is what drew brees had
to say I will never agree with anybody
disrespecting the flag of the United
States of America for our country let me
let me just tell you what I see or what
I feel when the national anthem is
played and when I look at the flag of
the United States I envision my two
grandfathers who fought for this country
during World War two one in the Army and
one the Marine Corps both risking their
lives to protect our country and to try
to make our country in this world a
better place so every time I stand with
my hand over my heart looking at that
flag and singing the national anthem
that's what I think about and in many
cases it brings me to tears thinking
about all that he's been sacrificed not
just those in the military but for that
matter those throughout the civil rights
movements of the 60s and everyone and
all that has been endured by so many
people up until this point and is
everything right with our country right
now no it's not we still have a long way
to go but I think what you do by
standing there and showing respect to
the flag with your hand over your heart
is it shows unity it shows that we are
all in this together we can all do
better and then we are all part of the
solution
that's true breeze with his own personal
experience as to what the flag means to
him and he's entitled to his him his
opinion right we're all entitled to our
opinions the problem is at a time like
this when you articulate an opinion that
is not going to mesh with what some
regard as the overwhelming mood which is
hey we should have listened to Kara Nick
hey it was never about disrespecting the
flag hey why are you still saying it was
about disrespecting the flag now right
we know what we know and why we are
discussing what we are discussing I saw
someone point out well drew didn't say
anything differently today than he said
four years ago okay he didn't that's
fine but four years ago was a very
different time in a very different mood
in a very different place and even then
look I was never a big fan of this whole
ignoring what Colin Kaepernick is saying
and dismissing it by saying don't
disrespect the flag don't disrespect the
military when he's saying that's what
I'm trying to do I'm ready to bring
attempt I'm using the platform I have to
bring attention to a problem that is
very serious and it's very personal to
me and I feel strongly about it so look
here's the bottom line
what drew brees said yesterday and I'm
sure he had no idea the fuse he was
lighting and and I know when I saw the
comments I thought this this there's a
chance that this is going to become a
problem for him throughout the course of
the day well it immediately became one
because in this age of social media
where we all have the opportunity to
broadcast our opinions our views our
reactions whenever we want to and
however we want to the the reaction will
be there when the emotions are raw
Michael Thomas Saints receiver you know
it was more subtweeting than anything
else as the kids call it Chris but he
came after Drew Brees it's unmistakable
he don't know no better one of the
tweets from Michael Thomas yesterday in
the immediate aftermath of Brees
comments and then we don't care if you
don't agree and whoever else how about
that and again it all comes back to the
idea that in this moment in this time
it's not about disrespecting the flag
and I think if the season were to start
today there may be more guys taking and
there are guys standing frankly if the
sad words start today now
knows where we're gonna be three months
from now but right now in the aftermath
of what happened to George Floyd and
what's gone on over the past week and a
half the unity would be in the kneeling
not in the standing Chris so that that
was just that was just a taste of how it
all got started
drew brees then provided some
information to Mike triplet of espn.com
some clarification some additional
information I love and respect my
teammates and I stand right there with
them in regards to fighting for racial
equality and justice I also stand with
my grandfather's who risked their lives
for this country and countless other
military men and women who do it on a
daily basis and and look he's trying to
harmonize his views with the views of
teammates and others but look it didn't
work it didn't take it didn't take as
the day went on the Malcolm Jenkins
reaction was powerful to say the least
Chris and here let me let me tell you
what happened and for anybody out there
wasn't paying attention to say there was
a very raw very emotional video that was
posted by Malcolm Jenkins who plays for
the Saints posted it it was very very as
I said raw and emotional and personally
directed to Drew Brees and what he said
that video was deleted it was replaced
by another one that was recorded before
Malcolm Jenkins had a conversation with
Drew Brees but he explained on Instagram
that he had the conversation with Brees
but he still wanted to post the video as
I was trying to muster up the energy and
find the words to address Drew Brees
comments I recorded this video before I
could post it drew reached out to me to
discuss his point of view
all in all I'm still posting this video
because it's important for anyone who
wants to consider themselves an ally to
know how these words and actions affect
those who you want to help Drew's words
during his interview were extremely
painful to hear and I hope he rectifies
them with real actions that was the
setup now before I play the video Chris
and I'm sorry I've been I look the this
is not an easy day I'm trying to get the
information out there but I want us to
have a conversation as it relates to the
drew brees comments that that were made
and the reaction and and I look it is
what it is I mean that that's the thing
it happened
there's nothing we can really say other
than it happened and I understand why it
happened because in this moment to go
back and real it again whether or not
colin kaepernick was sending a message
or disrespecting the flag it this isn't
the time for that this is the time for
saying hey Colin Kaepernick was right
folks and maybe we should listen to him
well yeah exactly
I mean you know that I think that's
really what infuriated me and other
players in the NFL about Drew Brees
comment you know we didn't make any
progress over the last four years
because the subject when Colin
Kaepernick had brought it up got changed
to kneeling to the flag and
disrespecting our country in the
military which couldn't have been more
false so that's the first reason players
are mad because it's basically Drew
Brees has given the propaganda to the
other side the racists of the world
again to sit there and change the
subject because they don't want to deal
with the reality of what is going on
right now so I think that is the biggest
issue you know and then when you go on
this you know tirade about what the flag
means to you and you don't want to
disrespect the country and you're more
passionate about that and the anti
kneeling aspect and yet you don't talk
about a guy who kneels on a guy's throat
for nine minutes and kills them of
course that's gonna piss off African
American players on the NFL so that's
where it comes off as insensitive to
Jeru Brees listen I don't think Drew
Brees is a bad guy I really don't I
think he's a really good guy
um do I think he can be a little
political than his answers at time and
be that way yes and I think that's kind
of what got him in trouble yesterday I
do but I think that's ultimately why
he's getting the backlash he's getting
and it's why I'm you know I'm
disappointed and other players are
disappointed because we've moved past
that it's over you know if we didn't
change the subject to oh we don't like
the country and don't like the military
maybe we would have had more progress
over the last four years and we wouldn't
be sitting here with you know again
three or four African Americans who have
unjustly been murdered over the last you
know month and a half or whatever it may
be now as far as
the timeframes concerned and maybe we'd
be farther down the road and progress
here but I think that's the biggest
issue at hand I know that's what
bothered me and yeah I think it's really
upset the african-american athlete who
of course has been in the trenches and
trying to you know make the world better
and fight the good fight as far as this
subject is concerned and you know they
feel like this brings them back a little
bit it's like taking two steps back in
this conversation yeah and the
conversation on this point will continue
I think now is the appropriate time to
share with you the second video that was
created by Malcolm Jenkins again it was
created before he spoke to drew brees
but he decided Jenkins did to post the
video following his conversation with
drew brees here is what Malcolm Jenkins
ultimately posted as his second video on
social media I promise you this the
onslaught of that we have to deal with
it's crazy right now drew Brees
if you don't understand how hurtful how
insensitive your comments are you are
part of the problem
[Music]
to think that because your grandfather's
served in this country and you have a
great respect for the flag that
everybody else should have the same
ideals and in thoughts that you do is
ridiculous and it shows that you don't
know history because when our
grandfathers fought and for this country
is served and they came back they didn't
come back to a hero's welcome they came
back and got attacked for wearing their
uniforms they came back to people to
racism to complete violence and then
here we are on 2020 with the whole
country on fire everybody witnessing a
black man dying at the hand of a
murdered at the hands of the police with
isn't just in cold blood for everybody
to see the whole country is on fire and
the first thing that you do is criticize
one's peaceful protest that was years
ago when we were trying to signal a sign
for help and signal for our allies and
our white brothers and sisters the
people we considered to be friends to
get involved it was ignored and here we
are now with the world on fire and you
still continue to first criticize how we
peacefully peacefully protest because it
doesn't fit in what you do and your
beliefs without ever acknowledging that
a fact that the man was murdered at the
hands of police in front of us all and
that it has been continuing for
centuries that the same brothers that
you break the huddle down with before
every single game the same guys she
believed with and gone about it with
every single day go home to communities
that have been
decimated Juran unfortunately my
personally you're somebody who doesn't
understand their cookies you don't
understand the potential that you have
to actually be an advocate for the
people that you call brothers you don't
understand the history and why people
like me people with my skin color whose
grandfathers fought for this country who
served and I still protested against
that against the not against the
national anthem but against what was
happening in America and what our fed
that fabric of this country is poor or
stands for if you don't understand that
other people experience something
totally different in you
then when you talk about being the
Brotherhood and all this other book it's
just lip service or it's only on the
field because when we step off this
field and I take my helmet off when I'm
a black man walking around in America
and I'm telling you I'm dealing with
these things I'm telling my communities
are dealing with these things and your
response to me is don't talk about that
here
this is not the place you where's the
place drew I'm disappointed I'm hurt
because while the world tells you that
you're not worthy that your life doesn't
matter the last place you want to hear
from are the guys that you that you go
to war with and that you consider to be
allies and to be your friends
even though we're teammates I can't let
this lie as Malcolm Jenkins more than
four minutes it was posted yesterday and
it is raw it is emotional
he becomes choked up on multiple
occasions sharing his own experience and
I think that's the key Chris and I think
for those of us who haven't lived it now
is the time to find out what others have
dealt with the people that we know and
you witnessed it as a teammate in locker
rooms both at Texas and with the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers and other NFL team so you
have been around guys who have been the
victims of anything but equality but I
think we all to the extent that we
interact with that we work with that we
know that we are friends with if we have
family members who have that experience
the the point is you know what we kind
of go about our lives and we're numb to
it we're blind to it we don't live it we
don't know what it is now's the time to
really take a step back and find out
what people have been dealing with when
they have been on the wrong side of the
majority when they have been on the
wrong side of law enforcement when they
have been the victims of systemic and
specific discrimination Chris yeah well
it's it's been going on in our society
for way too long and you know as I've
talked about before yeah you know I
thought I had a pretty good idea growing
up it's still some Sun being around
african-american athletes and people and
oh well I I kind of know what they're
going through absolutely not you you
can't until you you know spend
significant amount of time and and get
into you know certain places or get
around law enforcement to start to
realize whoa they will they do treat you
a little differently sometimes than your
skin's a different color and all those
issues so Malcolm Jenkins has been you
know one of the biggest advocates in
this fight altogether
he's very smart he's well thought-out
he's passionate and I'm sure he didn't
like calling out drew brees there and
doing that I don't think he wanted to do
that but when you're the face
you know advancement for the
african-american community in America
and Malcolm Jenkins is one of those
faces for the NFL he can't let a
teammate slide with that type of comment
because this is bigger than football
this is life and a guy like Drew Brees
can really sway some minds and sway the
way people think and Malcolm Jenkins and
other guys are in this fight with him
would look very hypocritical if they
didn't call out Drew Brees because he
was just their teammate or a guy that
was really good at playing quarterback
in the NFL so not easy to do you know
again I don't think drew I don't I want
to make this clear I don't think Drew
Brees is a bad person I don't do I think
he's maybe a hair self-righteous
righteous and his you know his thoughts
are a little mixed up yes I do
definitely but I think what Malcolm
Jenkins said was very powerful and
really spot-on in a lot of ways well and
let's remember this Malcolm Jenkins has
been at the forefront of the effort to
affect change by four years since Colin
Kaepernick tried to get our attention
so look just like there are two Americas
there were two American reactions to
what Colin Kaepernick did there were
those out there who decided to ignore
his message because they didn't like his
method we don't like his methods so
we're gonna plug our ears to his message
then there were those like Malcolm
Jenkins who took the message to heart
and used it as a way to spur action
which is what makes the fact that
Jenkins is now back on the Saints after
six years with the Eagles even more
relevant and impactful to the discussion
that emerges in the aftermath of what
drew Brees had to say Jenkins is the
authority he's got the time invested
he's got the experience in fact he's got
his soul invested in trying to end these
problems and he's been very effective
along with the players coalition in
making things better and I think that
that from his perspective when we
immediately rewind to 2016 and used the
same deflections that were employed to
ignore the message that feels like
taking the work that he's done over the
last
for years crumpling it up into a ball
and throwing it into the trash can which
i think is why he reacted as emotionally
as he did one of the reasons why many
reasons I think behind the very
emotional reaction but let's not go back
to 2016 it's not 2016 circumstances have
changed and I think the prevailing
reaction in America is or at least
should be man we should have paid more
attention to what Colin Kaepernick was
trying to tell us
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports